what's the best way for me to to get
wealthy like like I don't want to say
rich but like wealthy is like the best
way be very intentional with your money
most people just kind of wander along
and then wonder what happened and if
you'll just be very intentional then
that will lead you to doing a budget
that will lead you to living on less
than you make that will lead you to
generosity that will lead you to
avoiding debt uh that will lead you to
investing and those are the keys to
Building Wealth but no one does that
accidentally no one wins the Super Bowl
on accident it's an intentional act and
so just by asking the question you've
started that process of being
intentional